IN OTHER NEWS --
KENTUCKY CLERK AND
HUCKABEE-PROCLAIMED SECOND
COMING OF M.L.K. KIM DAVIS WENT
BACK TO WORK TODAY TO DO WHAT
AMERICANS DO BEST -- AVOID
ACTUAL WORK.
>> KIM DAVIS TOLD THE MEDIA SHE
WILL NOT AUTHORIZE LICENSES ON
HER FIRST DAY BACK.
>> ANY UNAUTHORIZED LICENSE THAT
THEY ISSUE WILL NOT HAVE MY
NAME, MY TITLE OR MY AUTHORITY
ON IT.
INSTEAD, THE LICENSE WILL STATE
THAT THEY ARE ISSUED PURSUANT TO
A FEDERAL COURT ORDER.
>> Larry: SO YOU'RE TELLING ME
KIM DAVIS IS COLLECTING A
GOVERNMENT PAYCHECK IN ORDER TO
SIT AROUND AND LET EVERYONE ELSE
DO ALL THE WORK?
I THOUGHT WE CALLED PEOPLE LIKE
THAT WELFARE QUEENS...
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY!
UNFORTUNATELY, LIKE A BIGOTRY
HYDRA, YOU CUT OFF ONE HEAD AND
MORE SPRING UP.
THERE ARE 12 OTHER CLERKS AND
JUDGES IN KENTUCKY,
NORTH CAROLINA AND ALABAMA
COPY-CATTING KIM DAVIS'
STRATEGY.
ONE CLERK EVEN RODE HIS BIKE
ACROSS THE STATE IN SUPPORT OF
HER.
RODE HIS BIKE? GOOD LORD!
I TELL YOU THIS -- THERE IS NO
WAY IT'S MORE EFFECTIVE THAN HOW
I CHOSE TO
SUPPORT FOR "THE STRAIN" BY
SPACE-BOARDING DOWN THE WEST
SIDE HIGHWAY.
THAT WAS NOT EASY.
SO KIM DAVIS IS NOT ALONE, AND
THAT'S AWFUL BECAUSE, DESPITE
WHAT SHE SAYS, THIS ISN'T ABOUT
RELIGIOUS LIBERTY.
IT'S ABOUT USING RELIGION AS AN
EXCUSE TO DENY SOMEONE ELSE'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT?
AND THAT'S WHY IT WAS SO AWESOME
WHEN I FOUND OUT THESE GUYS WERE
GETTING INVOLVED.
>> THERE WERE QUESTIONS ABOUT
THIS GROUP OF HEAVILY ARMED MEN.
THEY CALL THEMSELVES
OATHKEEPERS.
P.D.
>> THIS IS JUST ABOUT KEEPING
PEOPLE SAFE.
>> Larry: UM...
I THINK JAMES BLAKE COULD USE
YOUR HELP.
AND THE BROTHER THAT LOOKS LIKE
JAMES BLAKE.
(LAUGHTER)
OKAY.
SO THESE OATHKEEPERS ARE A GROUP
OF PEOPLE WHO COME HEAVILY ARMED
TO AWKWARD CIVIC CONFRONTATIONS
WITH THE INTENT OF PROTECTING
THE CONSTITUTION.
THEY'RE KIND OF LIKE THE WHITE
BLACK PANTHERS.
I MEAN, TECHNICALLY, THEY'D BE
WHITE PANTHERS, WHICH WOULD
TECHNICALLY BE SNOW LEOPARDS.
(LAUGHTER)
I MEAN, I COULD GO ON, BUT WE'D
JUST GO INTO A LINGUISTIC SPIRAL
AND THIS BIT WOULD NEVER END.
LET'S JUST CALL THEM WHITE
LIONS.
OKAY.
SO THESE ALBINO TIGERS HAVE
TAKEN IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
PROTECT KIM DAVIS BECAUSE "SHE"
IS THE VICTIM HERE.
NOT THE PEOPLE WHOSE ACTUAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS ARE BEING
TRAMPLED ALL OVER.
SO WHAT DO THESE IVORY PUMAS
HAVE TO SAY FOR THEMSELVES?
>> THE ISSUE IS STILL THAT A
JUDGE TOOK AN ELECTED OFFICIAL,
A CITIZEN OF THE UNITED STATES
AND DETAINED THEM WITHOUT CAUSE.
>> Larry: WITHOUT CAUSE?
LOOK, KIM DAVIS WAS PUT IN JAIL
BECAUSE A JUDGE LEGALLY HELD HER
IN CONTEMPT OF COURT.
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARM THEMSELVES TO
PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION, YOU
SHOULD TRY READING IT.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR
PRESENCE TO BE KNOWN BECAUSE
IT'S NOT AN ISSUE OF MARRIAGE.
>> Larry: NO, IT IS AN ISSUE
OF MARRIAGE.
DON'T TRY TO CHANGE THE SUBJECT.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT SOMEBODY USING
RELIGION BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE
GAY MARRIAGE.
AND BY THE WAY, GAY COUPLES ARE
LITERALLY EXERCISING THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO TAKE AN
OATH OF MARRIAGE, YOU ALLABASTER
MOUNTAIN CATS!
(LAUGHTER)
TO TELL US MORE ABOUT THE THIS
GROUP, JOINING ME NOW FROM
KENTUCKY ARE THREE
OATHKEEPERS -- TROY HOLZER,
TRAVIS HAGSTROM AND TRENT
HALVERSON!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> EVENING, SIR -- IT'S FREEDOM
TIME!
(GUNFIRE)
>> Larry: CALM DOWN, GUYS.
NO GUNSHOTS, PLEASE.
OKAY, SO WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU
PROVIDING?
>> SAFETY, LARRY.
WE'RE HERE TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE.
>> Larry: WELL, ISN'T THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE POLICE?
>> NO, APPARENTLY THE PURPOSE OF
THE POLICE IS TO ARREST KIM
DAVIS FOR DOING NOTHING WRONG.
>> OH, WE'LL FIGHT THE SHERIFF
IF WE HAVE TO!
(GUNFIRE)
>> Larry: OKAY, GUYS.
STOP IT!
(LAUGHTER)
HOW ARE YOU SHOOTING MACHINE
GUNS IN FRONT OF A GOVERNMENT
BUILDING WITHOUT GETTING
ARRESTED?
>> WE'RE WHITE -- CAN YOU NOT
SEE US? YOU SHOULD TRY IT
(LAUGHTER)
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: SO LET ME SEE IF I
CAN GET THIS STRAIGHT.
YOU GUYS ARE AGAINST THE
UNLAWFUL DETENTION OF KIM DAVIS,
BUT GAY PEOPLE ARE BEING
"UNLAWFULLY DETAINED" FROM
GETTING MARRIED!
>> TWIST THOSE WORDS ALL YOU
WANT, HOLLYWOOD!
YOU KNOW WHAT THE ENEMY OF
FREEDOM IS?
LAWS!
>> YEAH!
THAT'S HOW COME WE UPHOLD THE
CONSTITOOSH!
AMERICA'S NUMBER ONE!
WHOO!
(GUNFIRE)
>> Larry: STOP SHOOTING!
LOOK, YOU JUST SEEM LIKE GUYS
WHO WANT TO DRESS UP IN
UNIFORMS, SHOW UP AT RALLIES AND
JUST FLAUNT YOUR GUNS.
>> UH-HUH.
THAT IT?
NO QUESTION?
>> Larry: YOU'RE NOT EVEN
WANTED.
KIM DAVIS' LAWYER SAID SHE
REJECTED YOUR OFFER TO BE THERE.
>> SINCE WHEN DO LAWYERS KNOW
ABOUT THE LAW?
>> WE'RE OATHKEEPERS, NOT
OATH-LISTENERS.
>> FREEDOM AIN'T FREE!
LIGHT 'EM UP!
(GUNFIRE)
>> Larry: OKAY, THAT'S ENOUGH.
THE OATHKEEPERS, EVERYBODY.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.